yep there elements of the crime that's
demonic but this is the part where you
you cook your own self because you
believe in the Bible and according to
your Bible the devil cannot go against
himself do you know how many times the
Quran say I seek Refuge from the devil
that's not the
devil ain't no way man you you you
believe you believe Shayan is El don't
you ain't no way man yeah you you
believe that no way you just say that
you believe the devil is some genin
named right I Ain no way you just said
it yeah is that correct he yeah yeah
yeah all right can you show me in the
Bible where it says that that Satan is
is some Gin named he BS I
know I know have a nice day I
know take care hey man I got a quick
question for you m what's up okay so
when I was a Christian I didn't really I
didn't really have an opinion on the
Quran so I don't really know even when I
do my Paradigm shifting I don't have an
opinion because I don't really even know
I don't even think I knew the Quran
existed when I was a Christian so but
according to your Christian Paradigm who
do you think wrote the Quran dude I have
no idea but like but if you were if you
were to make an assumption like your
best educated guest who do you think BR
the court wrong I would think that I
would think that maybe some people had
got together and
and and wrote the Quran man I really I
really okay let me ask you this let me
just be more specific do you think do
you think the devil wrote the Quran no I
don't think the devil wrote the Quran so
do you think do you do you 100% disagree
with the Christians that claim the
quran's from the devil oh how about this
let me word it to you like
this do you even give a 1% chance that
the Quran could have possibly been
written by the devil I don't think that
the Quran is written
because by
any spiritual figure obviously men wrote
it oh the devil inspired it whatever you
want to say yeah yeah I do believe that
there are some elements that are
demonically inspired okay good good good
this I'm about to cook you there
elements that are okay okay I hear what
you're saying so now I'm about to cook
you then wait so can you repeat what I
said so I make sure you're you're right
there some elements in the Quran that
was inspired by the dev that are demonic
yeah yeah okay do you believe in your
Paradigm the Bible take you to heaven if
you follow the Bible you gonna go to
heaven yeah I do okay so you which if we
follow your logic I'm G say this slowly
I'mma hold your hand for you use your
logic logic all right I'mma hold your
hand when I tell you this so according
to you you believe if you follow the
Bible it's going to take you to heaven
and your Christian Paradigm right yeah
so if you keep claiming with this ridic
ridiculous argument that the Quran
confirms the Bible you basically saying
the devil telling the people to go run
back to the Bible that could take them
to Heaven well I I like this that you're
trying to use hamza's argument yeah yeah
there you go yeah so like I said I don't
believe that everything in the Quran is
inspired by the devil I believe this
there are some elements of it that are I
believe the other parts are man-made you
can clearly see that m wanted the people
to believe in him as a prophet so he
appealed to their
scriptures
so that's um the part that's manmade you
can see Muhammad's desires all over okay
okay this is the part I'm about to cook
you even more because you really not
making sense hey I'm go and explain to
you how you don't make sense all right
all right cook me man cook me how many
times will Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon Him mentioned in the Quran how
many times how many times what how many
times was Muhammad by name mentioned in
the Quran
four four times yeah so according to
your Paradigm you believe the devil
Inspire Muhammad to tell the people to
follow the Bible which in your Paradigm
mind you your Bible you claim is gonna
lead you to
heaven hold let me finish let me finish
you're starting off on a straw man bro
I'm no my brother hold on what what did
I what did I say to you before you
started this what did I just say to you
bro you said certain parts of the Quran
right that's what you saying right and
so what did I say specifically about the
parts of the Quran that confirm the
Bible what did I say about those parts I
don't know what you say what you you
said there certain elements of the Quran
that affirm your Bible
yeah know and then what did I then say
specifically about the parts that
confirm the Bible those claims what did
I say specifically about that I don't
know say it again that's crazy see you
you said you said see I see what you're
saying and I'm about to cook you even
more on that yeah I am Pati
okay just I'll say it again dude I'll
say it again and then and then cook me
on this okay so I see I got you I got
you said that you can see clearly in the
Quran the man-made elements in it and
part of the man-made elements are the
parts where Muhammad you can see his
desire to be accepted by the Jews and
Christians as a prophet so he appeals to
their books I believe that those are
that's Muhammad's man-made
desires so he puts himself as a confirm
uh as a fulfillment of their scriptures
as a prophet foretold in their
scriptures and so on and so forth so say
okay I understand what you're saying
okay may I respond to you as long as you
respond to what I said yes go ahead okay
yeah I'm going respond to you but but
how much of a filter do I what do I need
like how filter do you want my response
right now just go go ahead and respond
man just you know go ahead okay okay my
brother I'mma hold your hand when I tell
you this man see like I gotta hold your
hand yeah I'mma Hold Your Hand walk with
me now hold on all right I'm walking
with you that is the most ridiculous
stupidest argument I done ever heard in
my life man because then you will argue
what the hell is the point of the
Quran what what the hell is the point of
it
according to your Paradigm if you think
the Quran affirms your Bible and you
think Muhammad did this and that and
first of all you even agree that
Muhammad was an illiterate man you think
he did it to get to get validation from
the Jews and the Christians come on man
you know even deep down in your mind and
soul you don't believe that argument man
what um what what what uh objections do
you have to what I said cuz all saying
that saying that my argument is stupid
is not an argument
let me tell you this let me tell you
this right now Avery if I tell you right
now are you outside right now Noe okay
let's just pretend you're outside what
color is this guy man it looks like it's
blue it's blue right but if I told you
Avery go step outside man and you step
outside and I tell you man the sky like
the sky like caramel man it's like
caramel color the first thing you going
to tell me man that's a stupid ass
statement not every statement needs a
rebuttal man something is just stupid no
I'm going to say look outside at the sky
is that caramel or is that blue see
I'mma point you to a reference to show
you why what you're saying to show you
why what you're saying is stupid okay
let me respond to that you go ask me
that question but you go this is the
this is the tricky part for you you
going to stumble across a idiot like you
right that's gonna say no man it's
caramel man it's caramel sometime you
stop you know in everyday life man
everyday life you going to stumble
across people that are so delusional
they just say the most irrational things
and no matter what you say I'm just
waiting on an argument man you get what
I'm saying that is the argument man you
making a claim hey so the argument is
logic you stupid you I didn't say you
stupid my brother you did you did you
said you g you said you're going to come
across an idiot like you that's what you
say you call me an idiot so okay yeah I
mean idiot is less it's not as bad as
stupid no it's a same thing but so you
said you calling me an idiot calling me
stupid I'm saying that my argument is
stupid but you haven't giving me a an
objection so and I I know you that's
where you fa you think everything say
I'm about to give you the floor right
back okay go ahead I want you to bring
an objection to this idiot show me that
what I'm saying is illogical is idiotic
show me that show me that don't just
tell me that I'm stupid for this show me
it what's what's your objection okay let
me show you then let me show you at the
end of the day man everything you keep
saying that's why I started out the
conversation by asking you because
because as many times as I I mean I
listen to you a couple of your lives a
lot of times and then you know obviously
I join your panels a lot but I was like
you know what let me not make an
assumption cuz I don't think I ever
heard Avery make this make his statement
or or or state his opinion so I like you
know what hey hey don't even don't
assume just ask the brother a who do you
think in your Paradigm or just your
opinion wrote the Quran you immediately
said I don't know that's what you said
right you said you don't know so you
making claims about the Quran but you
don't according to you by own admission
you don't even know who wrote the Quran
man I never made a claim about who wrote
it but if you don't know who wrote the
Quran how can you assume what the
intention of any of the characters in
the Quran is is doing by its contents
its content shows the intention so by by
the contents of the Quran I can see that
the author wanted Muhammad to be
accepted by the Jews and Christians by
the contents of the Quran I can see that
uh that Muhammad had a desire for women
because he was able to have as many
wives as he wanted while the other
Muslims could only have four by the
concept of the Quran I can see that
Muhammad wanted power you have to obey
Allah just you have to obey the
messenger like you obey Allah um you
can't have faith unless you submit to
Muhammad with full submission with no
resistance I see that Muhammed by the
contents of the Quran wanted money he
got a certain percentage of the war
booty that they went out when they P
when they went out to pillage Villages
he got a large percentage of the money
while others went to the one percent of
went to Allah another to Mohammad and
another to his family come on man that's
all going okay
okay I can see the intentions oh and
here's another thing I can see that the
intentions of the author that Muhammad
didn't want to you know be me seem to
come off mean to certain people so he
was too scared to tell people hey man
when you come over eat your meal and
just leave don't stay here talk ask all
these questions but the Quran says for
him and he he just says Allah told me to
say this so I get what you're
saying I see where you coming from hold
on so let me let me respond so I think
the reason I'm asking you these
questions is because as many times as I
heard you I was like you know what what
is every stance on the Quran so with
that being said because I really I
really do try to understand your
Paradigm I really do that's that's
really why I be listening sometime to
you know I mean I really try to
understand where you coming from but my
question is if we could agree me you
right now could both agree Muhammad
didn't didn't write the Quran right sure
okay so if we could both agree Muhammad
didn't write the Quran you said the
authors wanted Muhammad to be accepted
what benefit or gain that the authors of
the of the Quran that you claim is it
Muhammad what benefit did they gain
according to you to make Muhammad be
accepted by the Jews and Christian what
was the benefit of the authors what was
that benefit you have and then and then
one one more thing though Avery one more
thing you also got to factor in the
Quran was written over 23 years there's
a lot of people that that'll do things
in this life they they keep at it for
maybe like six months three months a
year tops really but what man what
author you think gonna be committed to
writing a book for 23 years and it's
only to benefit muhamed you see where
I'm coming from my brother I'm trying to
I'm trying to make you think your
rationale don't make no sense my brother
it really don't because when you when
you ask yourself the question at the end
of the day as human beings we do things
for a benefit we are selfish creatures
man what benefit did these so-called
authors that you don't even know who it
is what benefit did they do did they get
out of it for writing a book for 23
years over a course of 23 years what
benefit they g go ahead easy you have a
a figure a figure head like Muhammad
whom you can use uh for Spiritual
manipulation um to Garner
control and uh have people obey your
every whim and follow your desires it's
easy power power control
all of that Sharia law all of that all
under the guise of Allah said so Allah
Allah said so through the prophet oh the
prophet taught this about women about
our desires about what men can have what
our rights are um yada y y all that so
you think they stayed dedicated for 23
years right to do that oh yeah okay and
will make it let me grant you that right
let me let me just go with that I can
say the same thing about your Bible
matter of fact there's actually some
truth in that regarding the Bible
because because at the end of the day
the end of the day it was infil at the
end of the day man the day G end man you
get what I'm saying right you feel what
I'm coming from like that's exactly what
I'm trying to tell you you see man at
the end of the day man you just really
don't make no sense man that's really
what I'm trying to tell you yeah but
you're not telling me how so I don't
think your rationale actually checks out
at the end of the day when you really
analyze your rationale it don't make no
sense that doesn't mean anything to me
hey the only thing that means something
to me is objectively showing that my
rationale does not make sense well why
do you why do you
think I guess I could word it to you
like this why do we got a force to
accept
arbitrarily your interpretation your
rationale it's like you just arbitrarily
say something you think okay yeah we
must accept this this this analysis it
don't make no sense my brother I'm not
even trying be mean to you it don't make
no sense well I didn't say that I didn't
say to arbitrarily accept what I'm
saying I'm saying to look at the
evidence that I present you know um I
you as you asked me about the man-made
you know features or elements right that
I think well why do I think that and I
laid out to you a couple of references
uh that that shows Muhammad's desires
and verses that are inspired by his
desires
you know what I'm saying I gave you some
of those examples you would have to I
mean I'm I'm saying look at those
yourself and make your judgment you a't
got to accept what I say but don't say
that I'm coming you know arbitrarily I'm
giving you uh references so I get what
you're saying but at the end of the day
it's like when you really so there's two
things like first of all your argument
regarding the Quran affirms the Bible
which you believe the Bible takes you to
heaven if you follow the Bible it's
going to take you to heaven which don't
make no sense right because essentially
you saying okay the the Muslims are good
because they got to they got to follow
the the the Bible so that's that's the
first flaw I see in your argument and
second of all wait wait explain that
flaw a little bit more how how is what
what's the flaw exactly okay the flaw is
this if you truly believe in your heart
that the Quran verse says we affirm the
Quran affirms the Bible we must you
don't have nothing to stand on unless
you follow the Bible right is that what
you're saying yeah that's what the crme
say then then then in in reality you
should really have no problems with the
Muslims you should be like oh man when
you read let me finish my brother hold
on okay when you when you look at the
Quran you're like oh the Muslims good
man they're going to Paradise because
they gota they got to read the Bible
because the scripture say you got to
affirm the Bible so you don't you really
should have any objections against the
Muslims according to your Paradigm
according to your conclusion of what
that verse say second of all is that you
guys don't you guys don't the Bible you
guys say you guys reject the Bible
that's my that's my beef with y'all your
Quran tells you to read the Bible and
believe in it but y'all don't that's my
beef with you okay and the second thing
is this this is mainly not for you but I
think you did make the claim matter of
fact you did make the claim so I do got
to hold you to it you said that there's
elements of the Quran that's that's
inspired by the devil correct yeah there
elements of the crime that's demonic but
this is the part where you you cook your
own self because you believe in the
Bible right and according to your Bible
the devil cannot go against himself do
you know how many times the Quran say I
seek Refuge from the devil that's not
the
devil ain't no way man you you you
believe you believe shayon is e don't
you Ain no way man some some Jin named e
hold on hold on ain't no way man yeah
you you believe that no way you just
said that you believe the devil is some
genin named El right I ain't no way just
said yeah is that is that correct hey
yeah yeah yeah all right can you show me
in the Bible where it says that that
Satan is is some Gin named B I know
way I know way have a nice day I know I
take
care oh man that dud is funny man ladies
and gentlemen hold
on you want me to believe that Satan is
some Jin who got tricked by Allah into
bowing down or not bowing down to Adam
that he's not one of the Angels but that
he's a Jin and Allah commanded the
angels to bow down El doesn't he's a Jin
not an angel so he didn't receive the
command and then Allah punishes him for
not bowing down when he didn't even tell
him to bow down in the first place and
then sentences him to Hellfire and so as
a result that prompts Satan to now be
against humanity and against Allah for
the rest of his days that you think
that's
Satan Ain't No Way M Ain no ain't no way
M ain't no ain't no way ain't no way who
ain't no way ain't no no no a Ain't No
Way Ain't No Way ain't no
way a no a no ain't no
way Ain't No Way ain't no way you want
me to believe that that say man you want
me to believe that El and say Ain't No
Way Ain't No Way ain't no way y'all not
about to see where I'm coming from y'all
see where I'm y y' understand what I'm
saying you understand what I'm saying
man